[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
on va parler évidemment de tout ce qui
va se passer dans les jours qui viennent
peut-être aussi de ce qui va se passer
donc on m'appelle le monde d'après et
pour en parler de laurent gbagbo est bon
jour n'ont pas traîné un jour à toutes
les langues de primes en 2000 78
évidemment vous allez nous raconter ce
qui se passe peut être dans votre ville
aussi puisque à ce que les écoles
reprennent qu'est ce que disent les
parents qu'est ce que disent les
enseignants
on va parler dans quelques instants la
série b bonjour bonjour patrice ça va
bien bonjour à tous alors plein de
formes pleine forme comme et on est ravi
de vous deux vous accueillez stéphane
minson bonjour bonjour patrick bonjour à
tous les soirs l'université de
versailles saint quentin va peut-être
parler qu'est ce qui va se passer pour
les examens comme très bien savoir ce
qu'est ce qui motive valable ou pas ce
que vous allez les faire passer le
comment rost bonjour bonjour vous êtes
membre du conseil économique social et
environnemental
aujourd'hui bull avait réussi chez régis
hochart la vanille boulot bonjour quand
m6 perd toujours brillé que nous sommes
que des mecs donc j'avais quand même
question importante à vous poser pour
commencer cette émission est ce que vous
ne pouvez pas quand même injuste
c'était beaucoup l'égalité des sexes et
des aides importantes que les femmes
sont moins frappés par le virus que les
uns c'est une question quand même là
essentiellement patrie si je peux me
permettre
elles sont frappées d'une autre manière
elles ont pour la plupart à supporter
leurs hommes ou leurs maris à domicile
depuis le confinement de manière
absolument régulière et on voit bien
d'ailleurs
et là il n'y a pas d'humour du tout dit
il on voit bien d'ailleurs les
problématiques que sa cause dans le dans
le cercle familial donc elles sont
vraiment - frappe effectivement par le
virus lui-même
elles sont frappées par les jeunes
d'hier les dégâts collatéraux de ce
virus ne soit pas que je pose est celle
d'or j'avais une deuxième pardon pas
tout de heureusement c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que ça a aggravé la situation
d'aider des couples qui est épié topé
mais j'avais une deuxième remarque
regrette c'est que le le virus de tubes
pas tous des toutes les personnes âgées
puisque vous avez une que giscard
poursuivis pour avoir mis la main aux
fesses à une journaliste allemande 94
ans doit être encore refermé on voit
mais patrice qu'il était arrivé la même
mésaventure à l'ancien président
américain george bush
à peu près au même âge d'ailleurs
quelques qu'il arrive cette mésaventure
à valéry giscard d'estaing et on peut
pas non plus exclure complètement je pas
si vous avez lu le les articles allemand
relatifs à ça je les ai pas recouvrir
soit pas non plus complètement exclure
qu'ils aient aussi une volonté pour
cette journaliste de de le faire
maintenant alors que la l'époque quand
ça s'est déroulé elle avait pas souhaité
le faire donc c'est pour pour nuire à
l'avenir politique de dsk
vous savez bien tous les anciens
présidents toujours de revenir alors on
va commencer par ce 11 mai qui approche
à grands pas dans quelques jours qu'est
ce qui va se passer vraiment devoir est
ce que vous attendez avec impatience et
du confinement je pense que par exemple
charles oui moi je l'attends avec une
impatience non dissimulée
à titre personnel parce que j'ai envie
de recommencer à vivre le plus
mal m'en possible et puis à titre
professionnel parce qu'effectivement
vasser plastique c'est le jour de la
réouverture des librairies des
bibliothèques des jeunes de tous les
endroits où l'on peut lire et de se
constituer
crytek est assez délivre donc c'est
primordial et ça va être de je pense et
knox un grand moment et jean boiteux
content de trouver de nouveaux livres de
pouvoir se joue excessive et se
distraire et et acheter des livres qui
n'ont aucun rapport que le cornac virus
donc là c'est effectivement très
impatient merci jean seul alors
christophe maury nous à nous à rejoindre
jour christophe vous êtes écrivain vous
avez vous aussi se demander comme ça est
ce que nous elle vous avez hâte que le
11 mai arrive à ce que vous avez écrit
un article qui n'étaient pas dans le
figaro que c'est nos bras enfin nombre
enfin deux de se prendre les uns dans
les autres de ses réseaux cas est-ce que
vous avez une âme comme ça que nous on
joue harry le 11 mai par dont paris
alors oui oui le 11 mai on n'aura plus
besoin a priori d'attestation pour
sortir ici je suis en normandie
malheureusement la plage est toujours
interdite et j'ai besoin de marcher sur
la plage comme vous l'imaginez mais ici
j'ai été contrôlé plusieurs fois par les
gendarmes qui est haute
autrement battre au nahd quotidienne et
qui me disait vous n'avez plus que s'il
vous est alors le 11 mai je vais pouvoir
marcher non pas une heure mais deux
heures mais trois heures
je pense que je vais prendre un petit
sac à dos j'ai pour un pique nique et je
vais aller pique-niquer loin loin loin
dans les bars est parce que les cigognes
sont arrivés alors je vais aller voir
les cigognes d'accord et pour le travail
on verra je n'ai qu'une autre fois ci le
grand cheval vous voyez un petit peu ce
qui se passe dans toute la france est-ce
que vous avez vous sentez comme ça il ne
sorte ma passion on a l'impression quand
même que autant les français ont accepté
le confinement pendant un moment
autant aujourd'hui il ya quand même une
envie de reprendre une vie plus normale
entre guillemets oui absolument patrice
la problématique c'est que
on l'a bien compris avec cette carte
déconfinement on sera pas tous logés à
la même enseigne
il y a évidemment des endroits où il est
toujours en haut sans aucun danger
d'aller se balader de reprendre une vie
tout à fait normale
et puis d'autres où ça va poser de vrais
problèmes donc moi ce que j'attends
maintenant ça va être la réaction des
gens face à ces problèmes qui vont
arriver
il ya vraiment une inégalité là alors
pour le coup démographique territoriale
géographique et sa saison le père soit
extrêmement à travers le grand jt du
territoire on voit bien qu'il ya des
inquiétudes qui sont focalisés ici ou là
voilà notre notamment à paris qui reste
quand même une zone qui constamment
rouge et en ile de france il y à des
zones qui n'ont jamais été problématique
on le dit pas et il ya des jours où on
en ferait il ya des problématiques
non je suis originaire oui et puis nous
insurger à bordeaux j'y suis à l'air à
plusieurs reprises il n'y a jamais eu la
même angoisse face à la propagation du
virus que kitty clé qu'il existe ici à
paris moi je suis à paris actuellement
donc voilà donc ça va créer une
disparité forcément alors plusieurs le
faire beau on rentre dans l'été je pense
que ces problèmes-là ce type de problème
là qu'on va connaître plus ceux qui vont
avoir rattrapé pendant ce qui aurait dû
être des vacances leur travail donc on
va vraiment assiste à une france qui
sera pas de vitesse mais voir a3 a4 a5
a6 a7 a8 a dit vitesse ça ça sera
problématique me semble justement le
conseil économique social et
environnemental dont vous faites partie
basse est une préoccupation la disparité
entre le territoire est ce que c'est
quelque chose que l'on craignait aussi
dans cette reprise à partir du 11 mai
même si elle est progressive un coup
tellement on travaille sur plusieurs
sujets en ce moment on travaille
notamment sur le rapport annuel sur
l'état de l'état de la france sur le
programme national de réforme est
effectivement sur le premier sujet il y
à ces questions là sur le plan européen
parce que mon nom une chose la sphère
internationale
on travaille plus sur le plan européen
effectivement ça va être un problème
ce qui les avait plusieurs en fait ce
qui est le plus inquiétant dans l'absolu
aujourd'hui c'est même pas le discours
du du du discours de l'exécutif qui est
juste d'une incohérence absolue où on
dîne justement il faut il faudra pas
traverser certaines zones qui sont en
les gens qui sont au rouge ne devrait
pas aller dans les zones qui sont vertes
sauf que on permet à tous et à toutes
les personnes qui sont dans l'espace
schengen de rentrer en france
sans aucun contrôle 114e et donc qui dit
à un moment les gens s'interrogent avec
tous les cours qui a lu avec toutes les
bêtises qu'ils ont fait depuis le début
de ce2 de cette crise
je ne compte pourtant comment il faut
encore une fois de plus pourrait être
d'un an
enfin pour faire les choses de cette
manière donc il ya un problème de fond
là dessus donc les français le
comprendre étant d'ailleurs ces mesures
là donc on apprend tous de savoir ce qui
va se passer
le par rapport aux 10 au discours du
milieu du premier ministre sur sa sur la
gestion de sa cité qu'on aura en
fonction de d2 la zone où on est donc
dire ce qu'on peut pas aller à reculons
qui sont km et de l'autre côté accepté
que tout le monde vienne de l'extérieur
et aider des pays qui ont été beaucoup
plus touchés que nous il ya une
incohérence extraordinaire dans dans
cette gestion on vous reconnaît pas en
reste vous épousez peut interdire aux
gens de venir de l'extérieur comme on
sait pas vos bêtises voulant mais
franchement on est très étonné de ce
discours est fade mort s'en tape là
dessus sagesse au passage est financé
par sa mère
s'il faut voir en effet c'est peut-être
une incompréhension dans la catégorie
catégorisation des personnes qui peuvent
entrer librement ou de manière moins
libre sur territoire français avec alors
ce qui peut se comprendre politiquement
s'il se comprend - salies terme ans avec
lui une sorte de deux laissez-passer
pour l'espace schengen si vous voulez ma
philosophie de l'espace schengen c'est
en effet la libre circulation alors
cette libre circulation à la connu des
restrictions récemment là elle semble
que il semble que ces restrictions
soit en voie d'être levé on veut show
plan sanitaire en effet s'interroger sur
le plan politique en tout cas sa une une
cohérence leur cohérence parfaite
laurent mazaury notamment qu' on
respecte est confiné avec la france
qu'avec n'ont pas la pression
le principe de précaution est devenu
quelque chose
une france qu'ailleurs c'est un vrai
j'aime et je pense que concernant le
corps la virus le bâti de précaution il
est pour une fois il trouve vraiment
toute sa justification patrie je
voudrais juste mois de suite souvent des
trucs le maroc je voudrais pas qu'on
compare le confinement du maroc avec les
jeunes
non mais je sais que c'est un point par
rapport à la libre circulation le maroc
vient vrai confinement il viendrait
confinement puisque quand quelqu'un sort
dans la rue
s'il n'a pas de justification il a une
amende paris devant ils ont voir il va
en prison au maroc
ce qui veut dire qu'on a du coup vous
noterez d'ailleurs à tour de propagation
du virus au maroc il 0,3 en france on
est remonté à 0 6 la semaine dernière
donc en dehors de l'aspect j'ai à dire
politique dont nous parlait place des
femmes est un instant je pense qu'on
doit avoir conscience que
tous nous sommes face toujours à une
pandémie j'entendais ce matin sur une
radio concurrente comme l'ont dit a volé
connu qui a les cheveux un petit peu
long avec une queue de cheval qui
rappelait en tout cas un professeur
d'après pour lui rappeler qu'ils avaient
un risque gens nommés qui avait donc un
risque de rebond très important mais
qu'il y ait essentiellement justement de
confinement c'est pour ça que pour moi
c'est pas si de précaution c'est juste
ce que la phase 2 par les siècles
combattu des pandémies quand on
n'arrivait pas à les contrôler je
rappelle la peste à marseille si vous
prêtez les documents de l'époque de la
grande peste marseille et que déjà à
l'époque les règles de confinement été
mis en place
c'est la seule tente n'avait d'ailleurs
de finir et donc vous avez raison
patrice pour dire que la france d'être
site de précaution mais dans le cas de
figure du co vite je pense qu'on compte
la france ne va pas assez loin et moi
pas du tout rassuré en tant qu'élu local
je suis désolé de le dire l'être humain
cauchemar est justement de ce qui va se
passer la semaine prochaine mais les
maires selon les responsables des écoles
mme qu'est ce qu'il va se passer le
lendemain les écoles rouvrent comment
qu'elle skie pas ce que disent les les
populations que deviendront ces lieux
alors comme vous le savez on a laissé
beaucoup de liberté aux maires là dessus
on leur a d'ailleurs envoyé une grande
part la responsabilité dont je peux
parler de ce qui se passe axel en cours
effectivement la semaine prochaine nos
écoles nous rouvrirons pas aux enfants
le 11 mai le 14 mai alors ouvrons par
contre pour l'ensemble des professeurs
qui voudront bien être là personnel le
on a bien entendu travaillé pendant
toute cette période dorée conditions
sanitaires difficiles pour la mise en
place d'un ensemble d'éléments de
sécurité ne vais pas répéter ici c'est
tout
donc il y aura ensuite trois jours pour
que le personnel à la fois pudique on a
entre autres les accès les éducateurs
professeurs test l'ensemble de ce
dispositif école par école qui a pas une
école qui ressemble à une autre c'est
directement liée à l'architecturé lieu
bien entendu puis le 14
ouvriront sur le principe de classe de
15 élèves avec des groupes de cas
constitue qui n'auront pas de transfert
une mixité entre pouvoir être vraiment
agir si des cas étaient avérés savoir
identifier les 14 autres personnes
nombre de ce groupe
la cantine est remise en place de
manière isolée pour chacun
et puis la grande le grand mystère
patrice c'est que nous avons donc fait
un sondage auprès de l'ensemble de la
population nous avons aujourd'hui un
tour de retour assez important qui nous
semble assez significatif et qui nous
donne le fait qu'elle est en cours 60%
des personnes qui auraient connu désir à
remettre leurs enfants à l'école
prochaine donc nous sommes partis de
cette statistique pourrait si les deux
groupes de 15
et puis la dernière chose c'est que nous
aurons probablement des surprises lors
de l'ouverture il se peut que des
professeurs fassent valoir et des
maîtres d'école des droits de retrait
c'est possible soit 4 11 soit le 12 en
regardant effectivement l'évolution des
différents process le 20 millions mis en
place soit même le 14 et donc il se peut
très bien
il se peut très bien des écoles qui ne
soit pas ouverte alors que d'autres le
seront si tout simplement pas le corps
professeur à présent voir voir nos
propres collaborateurs qui peuvent aussi
faire jouer leur droit de retrait ce
qu'il découvrait que ce qu'on a estimé
que les mesures efficaces dotées les
écoles voilà voilà où on en est la
demande
ce dernier point nous accueillerons bien
sûr les enfants alors nous avons décidé
de ne pas les accus en fonction des
niveaux
mais en fonction de la liste des
priorités que nous a été donnée par
gouvernement donc que les prends des
infirmiers des médecins des pompiers
genou ne l'oublié pas un service
prioritaire il ya les familles
monoparentales tombe bien le groupe
tient la garde est obligé d'aller
travailler
et puis les femmes qui ne sont pas moins
parental si les deux enfants les deux
bars dont les deux parents sont
également obligés d'aller travailler
voilà ce qu'on a mis en place à partir
de la semaine prochaine peut-être
stéphane manceau puisqu'on est dans le
concret est ce qu'il va se passer aussi
pour les étudiants reste que les examens
vont avoir lieu de telle manière est ce
que les cursus droit de valider ou pas
alors les s'agissant des étudiants les
étudiants ne pourront pas avoir accès
physiquement locaux universitaires au
moins jusqu'en septembre
et encore comme je vous l'avais signalé
nous préparons l'hypothèse
la possibilité d'une rentrée
universitaire à distance c'est-à-dire la
l'accomplissement d'un premier semestre
donc il va de septembre à janvier à
distance ou bien de manière hybride
c'est-à-dire avec des petits groupes qui
pourraient se succéder dans nos
amphithéâtres évidemment pas possible
d'accueillir avec des amphithéâtres de 6
ans de 600 personnes d'accueillir six
danseurs étudiants d'un coup pour les
examens les deux de façon générale et
dans l'ensemble des 60 78 aces et a
failli en a maintenant que - français
dans aucune hypothèse
les années où les semestre n'ont été
bradée donné c'était la revendication de
certains syndicats étudiants jeu mais
certains dans ce but liés forte
heureusement ça a été parfaitement
refusé c'était tout à fait inacceptables
évidemment parce que un diplôme c'est du
papier monnaie la valeur d'un diplôme si
simplement ce qu'il y a derrière la
valeur et la crédibilité d'un diplôme
c'est pas le diplôme en lui-même c'est
ce que ce diplôme représente donc et le
ministère a été parfaitement
parfaitement d'accord avec la
constitution dacquois par les
universités donc dans aucune hypothèse
les diplômes n'ont été ne seront données
validées sans épreuves d'examen pour les
examens et bien une part significative a
été donné au contrôle continu
après un peu sur le modèle si vous
voulez des baccalauréats étant entendu
que ordonna de ce contrôle continu nous
organisons les universités vont
organiser un certain nombre d'épreuves à
distance sous des formats évidemment
réduit la question qui était posée était
celle du pelage bien évidemment à un
étudiant qui chez lui peut avoir accès à
tous
moyens de communication possibles je
n'ose même pas dire à des livres parce
que lorsque des étudiants de première
année fréquentent les livres c'est déjà
presque un exploit mais en tout état de
cause si vous voulez pour en tout cas
dans nos disciplines à nous disputer une
juridique la question se pose même pas
parce que de façon générale ça a été
c'est mon cas en règle générale dans les
épreuves que soumet aux étudiants en
période normale
je leur laisse l'accès à tous leurs
cours je leur permets pas pour tous mais
assez souvent d'apporter tous les
ouvrages possibles et imaginables
certains arrivent même dans les
amphithéâtres le jour de l'épreuve avec
le une valise avec plein de livres pour
une épreuve de trois heures ce qui
m'intéresse c'est évidemment le
raisonnement le droit n'est pas née ça
n'est pas le théâtre ce qui est
important c'est la démonstration le
raisonnement donc voilà on forme un kino
épreuves sur des sur des modèles qui
permettent si vous voulez la mise en
place d'un raisonnement alors ce seront
des épreuves sur sur trente minutes sur
une heure au lieu des trois heures de
cinq heures habituelles sur ceux sur ces
mesures là qui sont prises que soit
posée comme ça pour les universités les
uns et les autres
christophe costes jean cyril et vous
pensez qu'on est un peu timorée ou que
sais tu tout bien ou quand trop de
risques ils ont commencé me patrice mas
mardi de même que tout à l'heure ça
dépend des endroits c'est le problème
des disparités
je pense qu'il comprend de très très
grands risques dans les zones où le où
le virus n'ait pas écouté je prends par
exemple je suis allé courir hier soir
cette espèce de mesure que totalement
débile que quelques caprices la mairie
de paris de nous obliger à ne pouvoir
aller courir entre 19 et 22 heures
c'est vrai qu'il y a full full à ces
heures là sûrement
j'habite à paris jeudi dans le 15ème
arrondissement sur les quais c'est
absolument hallucinant bon et on pouvait
imaginer qu'en ne prenons pas cette
mesure n'a tellement dans la journée
pourtant ce qui était le cas d'ailleurs
avant qu'elle ne soit prise voilà et
qu'on va se retrouver sur des situations
comme ça à localiser permanente de ce
type
donc il y aura effectivement des gens
qui vont prendre beaucoup de risques
dans ceux des confinement dans certaines
régions dans certains centres un endroit
où les clusters vont réapparaître
puis d'autres qui ne remet en aucun
risque c'est la problématique de ce duel
inégal immense et là ils peuvent que la
seule j'allais voilà un côté voile ont
tiré le gros lot au fond en fonction de
là où il habitera voilà enfin écoutez
moi je de plus plusieurs choses d'abord
suis extrêmement choquée de ce côté
facultatif la france semble être
maintenant une sorte de 2,2 grande agora
où tout le monde y va ça je le ferais ça
je ne veux pas ça je me mets en retrait
ça je le sens pas bien je vais rester
coucher je verrai demain on va se réunir
on verra alors là bon les écoles on dit
ben voilà c'est au bon vouloir des
départs en leur laurent vient de le dire
on verra quel professeur voudront bien
enseigner c'est une le monde d'après
s'annonce curieux c'est à dire que la la
sncf cherche à savoir si des gens
voudront moyens conduire les trains
parce que le droit de retrait s'exerce
donc on va trouver assez de gens pour
conduire des autobus est ce qu'on va
donc maintenant il n'y a plus
d'obligation on travaille si on veut
bien travailler bon bah tiens on va dans
le mur et on klaxonne
je veux dire c'est ça va être monstrueux
construire et quelle est cette idée de
dire est ce que vous voulez ou pas
envoyer les enfants à l'école enfin je
veux dire c'est aimer l'école est
obligatoire pour un final
et puis alors il ya les idées totalement
saugrenue de certains hommes politiques
on va réserver l'école aux nécessiteux
alors c'est vachement c'est pas du tout
discriminant ça vous dit alors vous vos
parents sont incapables de vous
apprendre quoi que ce soit à l'école on
vous accepte nouveaux parents sont
riches et cultivé pour vous accepte pas
mais on est au bout de leur temps aux
strauss ne répondra dessus mais piqué
story après mais non mais jean-charles
il faut il faut arrêter je alors
évidemment il ya une chose moi qui me
scandalise c'est effectivement que le
gouvernement se décharge à chaque fois
par rapport aux au mécontentement au
mécontentement des uns et des autres
donc dès que quelqu'un dit quelque chose
et disent ok bon bah allez prenez
allez-y donc c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas une ligne
directrice et en même temps dans le même
temps encore une fois on en revient à ce
que je disais allez sur l'émission de la
semaine dernière sur cette espèce de
schizophrénie qui est aussi dans notre
société
alors je suis désolé monsieur le maire
mais on a vu les maires qui ont demandé
plus d'autonomie plus de pouvoirs pour
pouvoir prendre des décisions lorsque il
ya eu cette mesure qui a été prise par
le maire de sceaux par exemple pour
imposer le port du loup pour imposer le
contenu ni deux les dires du cast du
masque dans les routes et le
gouvernement a dit non
l'assiette chose du prévôt sont les
mesures qui seront décidées par le
gouvernement
un nom à lumière où elle est viable
qu'il ya des mères qui se noie en zinc
oui mais c'est pas normal
et aujourd'hui pour les écoles ont donné
ok et vous prenez
débrouillez-vous fait appel et là ils
sont pas convaincus donc je pense qu'ils
ont il faut il fallut quelques
gouvernements dans la lütschine d'accord
avec avec jean-charles mais il leur
fallut fermeté réel de l'état au cas par
cas
par contre en question du double de
l'école vous avez des familles qui elles
n'ont pas forcément de la dînette
chainel qui sont parfois à cet abus dans
un appartement le tronc ou 40 mètres
carrés avec un seul ordinateur parce
qu'aucun et d'autres qui en ont même bas
donc comment vous faites pour nos gamins
qui sont à l'école pour qu'ils puissent
travailler dans l'eau
il ya plus juste extraordinaire je vois
la quantité du travail qui donnait
d'ailleurs parce que mon des deux
enfants et quand je les ai vus la
semaine dernière phrase semble je vois
la quantité de travail qui vient mais
c'est juste extraordinaire
et si vous contemplez vd si vous avez
une équipe à pouvoir les aider dans
leurs devoirs
comment vous faites donc qu'on ne
compterons permettent évidemment alors
ça peut paraître effectivement on peut
appeler un peu discriminatoire comme ça
à des gens qui ne trouvent que cette
manière là oui oui ceux qui veulent y
aller
izia y est effectivement vers les riches
d'avant l'heure encore activé pas les
exposer mes propres moyens
ainsi qu'est ce qu'ils font ils sont
obligés envoyaient leurs 23 résister ne
le fait que l'écart ne se creuse
métro a fait la une ras des pâquerettes
mais ce qui est perdu on va être
phénoménal pour qu'ils puissent les fans
alors vous aimez chanter nationale a été
donné pendant tout ce temps là prudente
et ce que l'on en fait d'une il était
quand même d'un sujet parce qu'il ya une
vraie profonde et il ya déjà en
investissement charles lajoie n'y a rien
avec des bêtises je dis simplement qu'il
faut pas discriminer les gens et que je
pense que arrivée à l'école et une
étiquette
je suis pauvre mes parents sont nuls ça
me paraît pas être une très bonne idée
que tout le monde aille à l'école
l'école signe un truc républicain tout
le monde doit y aller
les enfants de riches comme les enfants
de pauvres ne laissons le choix ni aux
parents ni au maire l'école est fait
pour accueillir et pour instruire les
enfants qu'elle fasse son boulot et
qu'on a eu on arrête de dire est ce que
par hasard on aura des enseignants qui
voudront bien enseigner les enseignants
doivent enseigner les parents doivent
emmener leurs enfants à l'école point
final
et elle ne lâche pas du gouvernement d'
absurde je le passé les gens énorme et
il n'y a pas qu'une lâcheté des
gouvernements vous voyez bien à tous
d'accord convenir que nos sociétés
n'accepte plus aucun risque on est
derrière ce parti du modèle anglo saxon
aux états unis ou pas faire un procès
aujourd'hui un an
quelle administration à n'importe quel
patron à n'importe quel on voit bien
qu'on est dans une judiciarisation
l'ensemble de tout ça où les gens
n'acceptent plus du tout de de prendre
le moindre et la société le veut exclure
tout risque qui nous mène d'ailleurs
dans une impasse puisque forcément la
vie à des risques forcément sortir dans
la rue en comporte un risque car et on
est là dans cette espèce de de course à
l'échalote de l'absence absolue du
risque zéro qui est devenu extrêmement
problématique dans nos sociétés ne
serait pas unique à la france les
problèmes qu'on connaît là c'est un
problème général
on n'accepte plus du tout le rôle risque
voilà effectivement réfléchir à ces
problèmes là et regarder comment les
défendant le oui non pour répondre à vos
ce que je vous demande pardon je
voudrais pas laisser penser que en ce
qui concerne l urp après nos
responsabilités en tout cas l encours
déjà la problématique de l'informatique
ne se pose pas puisque la totalité de
portes dotée d'ordinateurs puisque on
leur a tous donné des tablettes depuis
longtemps ainsi notre politique mais
mais sur le point de vous souper touche
lorsqu'on touche là à un fondement
fondamentale du mode de fonctionnement a
vu que nous voulons on a le choix entre
deux république jacobine et
centralisatrice dans lesquelles l'état
décide et tout le monde applique
c'est un point je me suis en période de
crise et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il
existait situation d'état d'urgence mais
ses fans n'ont pas fait beaucoup mieux
beaucoup mieux que moi à un moment donné
effectivement la démocratie locale et y
compris à à des politiques publiques
efficaces dans un délai rapide
c'est chaud je pense que c'est ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui où un modèle dans lequel
on va au bout la décentralisation et si
vous réfléchissez à lui des tractations
c'est une société dans lequel l'individu
prend toute sa place et décide quasiment
tout tout seul
d'accord donc aujourd'hui quand on est
face à une pandémie et je la tue je
pense vous pourrez tous d'accord
effectivement il faut que en local nous
appliquions des décisions qui sont
prises domaine gouvernementale quand
elles sont éclairées bien entendu par
l'éclairage des scientifiques
sinon ça serait un petit peu comme
autant d'habitants france que de
sélectionneur donc là on est quand même
quelque chose qui relève de la science
est effectivement nous dans les communes
on saurait de l'appliquer l'ambiguïté
sur les écoles elles relèvent du mode de
fonctionnement d'une école l'état
effectivement
de l'éducation nationale et d'éducation
qui donnait dans ses cales et pilote les
professeurs sauf que les élus et les
collectivités territoriales
c'est pareil pour les départements pour
les collèges et pour les régions
pourrait ici j'ai mon ce qui relève du
bâtiment et donc d'un scène de cogestion
7 correspond il fait effectivement qu'il
ya une coresponsabilité le point qui est
que les élus c'est quand on a reçu une
semaine dernière je vous aurais je vous
en prie regarder deux sur les réseaux si
vous le trouvez 70 pages 60 de
prescriptions techniques pas alors et là
on est dans ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est à dire dans la salle a
incité la république de notre barque
partout je verrouille tout je ne prends
pas de risques mais en réalité en
faisant ça je me déresponsabilise
évidemment que 70 passes et applicable
d'une part et donc ça j'ai été et c'est
pareil dans une entreprise si vous
mission à quelqu'un lui dit tu es libre
mais en même temps il va lancer 70
postes prescriptions légales ici vous
voudrez spécialisés dont alors juste un
point après je ne pardonne pas être trop
long on charge en charge en charge en
charge le gouvernement
moi je me demande toujours si c'est
pendant qu'il faut charger le sepa
l'administration qui est là de tout le
temps et qui demeure quel que soit
gouvernement parce que on va en parler
dans un instant parce que justement on
voit qu'il ya des différences entre les
jugements qu'une opinion par rapport aux
gouvernants christophe moret rien vous
qui pourrait être venir d'ailleurs
edimbourg gardien qui suit d'autogestion
au fond c'était ça pourrait revenir au
goût du jour christophe maury oui depuis
depuis quelques jours je voulais
m'entretenir justement avec stéphane sur
cette question là et là on a on a un
vrai problème juridique on a
l'impression aujourd'hui ce que tous les
responsables ont une trouille absolument
terrible d'être l'objet d'une plainte
pour je ne sais pas trop quoi parce que
il y aurait un alinéa d'un règlement qui
n'auraient pas été compris par par
l'ensemble de la population joue le jeu
vous donne un exemple nous pallions des
écoles
nous allons ouvrir l'école et imaginons
que mardi ou le mercredi suivant
l'agent qui s'occupe de la cantine tombe
malade du coronavirus est ce qu'il
pourra attaquer le directeur de l'école
voir le
mr en disant je suis atteint du
coronavirus parce que l'école a été
ouverte trop tôt et on a l'impression si
vous voulez aujourd'hui que tous les
responsables se cachent derrière une
administration folle qui est
complètement pointilleuse
on cherche à avoir tous les cas à ne pas
ne rien oublier
alors il faut être exhaustif vous
parliez tout à l'heure de du des 70
pages tournées pour les mères on cherche
le zéro défaut vous en parliez tout à
l'heure j'ai entendu toujours cette
expression
il faut que les conditions sanitaires
soient réunies les conditions sanitaires
soient réunies ça veut dire quoi
quel gamin qui fait du toboggan il va
falloir nettoyer demandant tout de suite
après alors conditions sanitaires et on
nous apprend aujourd'hui que il faudrait
mettre du chip chip sous les chaussures
qu'il faut un tiers plein de gestes en
dehors des gestes barrières qui sont qui
sont fondamentaux alors ça va un peu
loin et comme ça va un peu loin
eh ben j'ai l'impression que notre pays
va être un peu à la traîne par rapport
aux autres parce que d'autres états de
droit stéphane devons nous envoie la
balle
notre état de droit fait que aujourd'hui
on est plus dans une recherche plus si
vous voulez oui l'exhaustivité de zéro
les pauses qui n'existe pas
les jeux de l'aveyron risque
la france elle est sûre si bons rapports
et disserter au lieu d'agir et mais pour
10 septembre au cou mais c'est pas mon
jour peut-être il ya une différence à
faire des obligations oui il est
évidemment les questions sont
pertinentes et elle ne cesse de se poser
depuis que la crise a commencé je
rejoins ce que
disait cyril tout à l'heure c'est à dire
que si vous voulez tout cela est le
résultat d'un une tendance et peut-être
plus encore d'un besoin de la part de
chaque citoyen de pouvoir mettre en
cause la responsabilité d'une autorité
quelle qu'elle soit dans la survenance
d'un risque
lorsqu'un crise que ce s'accomplit
lorsqu'un dommages et provoquer il faut
toujours trouver un responsable
et si possible même un coupable donc le
bleu notre système juridique si vous
voulez un nenê que le que les connais
que le reflet de ce genre de
d'inquiétude voire d'angoissé manente la
loi est faite par des parlementaires qui
sont élus par les électeurs et donc la
loi est le reflet de ceux de sète ce
système d'amboise et puis d'autre part
et patrice le signal est aussi l instant
j'entendais par la voie du sénat l'autre
jour les élus locaux réclament et la
modification du droit applicable pour
justement les prémunir voir les protéger
à l'encontre de procédures qui seraient
trop fréquente est ce que christophe
évoqué tout à l'heure à l'instant et
justin la crainte c'est celle ci c'est
que rejoindre au moindre risque qui se
réalise on envoie nos élus et nos
responsables en prison or vous en
souvenez c'était en 2000 ça s'appelait à
l'époque les sas a toujours fait la loi
a été modifiée la loi fauchon qu'on
appelait la loi panneaux de basket vous
en souvenez un enfant qui se suspend
notre basket du parc municipal des
sports et qui se blesse et les le maire
ainsi que les adjoints responsables et
des membres de la fonction publique
territoriale sur eux en revanche ne pas
envoyer en prison mais enfin sont
condamnés à de la prison avec sursis
aujourd'hui c'est toujours ce même
ce qui s'applique et il est à mon sens
parfaitement suffisant pour couvrir les
risques d'excès de recours puisque pour
résumé l'élu ou l'administrateur ne sont
réellement responsables ne sont
coupables que dans la mesure où ils
auront manqué à une obligation de
prudence et l'obligation de prudence
c'est essayer de faire le mieux possible
essayer de se conformer du mieux que
l'on peut avec les moyens dont on
dispose aux prescriptions de sécurité
voilà donc tout cela si vous voulez pour
résumer ce n'est que le symptôme de ce
nom dans parlais tout à l'heure à savoir
le besoin pour chacun d'entre nous de
trouver un responsable voire un coupable
qui se répercute sur nos élus sur nos
administrateurs sur nos employeurs sur
nos congénères sur sur nos semblables
mais justement c'est ce besoin de
trouver un responsable
est-ce que ça n'explique pas une sorte
d'exception française libéraux
s'engagent du scénic beauf qui montrait
des attitudes de l'opinion vis-à-vis des
gouvernants on voit bien que 24% des
français qui font confiance à emmanuel
macron il ya 41% des italiens qui font
confiance a raconté il ya 48 % des
anglais qui font confiance à boris
johnson ne peut pas dire que la gestion
d'angleterre a été formidable et 60%
c'est peut-être plus compréhensible à
angela merkel mais est-ce que c'est pas
ça aussi une sorte d'exception française
d'hier sur le besoin de trouver à tout
prix des responsables même dans des
crises comme celle là qui sont
difficilement gérable d'une manière
politique ou est ce que ton bros disait
peut-être qu'on a mal géré la crise il
aurait menacé mais patrice je pense que
en france on peut dire qu'on veut mais
la crise a été extrêmement mal géré cela
marche
c'est une évidence je suis d'accord je
autant sur la partie il ya une partie
sur laquelle on peut rien leur reprocher
parce que personne ne connaissait
vraiment le virus
avait pas de recul dessus chaque jour il
y avait il y avait il y avait des
évolutions donc là-dessus bon moi je je
je pense qu'on peut pas les on peut
parler on peut pas les condamner là
dessus par contre sur une autre partie
si les révélations entre guillemets
d'agnès busin s'avère après l' enquête
je pense que il ya une responsabilité
lourde de la part du duo de l'exécutif
deuxième chose quand vous aviez une part
de moi juste busan avait prévenu bien
avant
connaissait il existe depuis sept mois a
dit qu'elle est bien voilà il emmène
alors que ça soit eux que ça soit qu'ils
avaient 10 avait tous les éléments pour
compte des mesures déjà dès le mois de
janvier mois sur la question c'est
plutôt moi sur la question de la gestion
des masques des masques je suis désolé
la diminution des masques a pris effet à
partir de la loi de programmation de
2013 2013 c'est pas ce gouvernement qui
était en place
donc au moment où c'était même la rode
programmation de 2011 qui a été
appliquée en 2013 d'ailleurs donc
c'était sous le gouvernement de nicolas
sarkozy ou la décision avait été prise
et elle a été appliquée sur le
gouvernement qui a suivi donc je pense
que ce gouvernement l'équipe un haut
responsable de ça ils auraient dû
prendre la responsabilité en disant leur
responsabilité en disant les masques
nous n'en avons pas assez expliqué au
progrès
pourquoi n'y en avait pas ensuite
réquisitionner les entreprises comme
renault qui n'avait pas besoin de
produire de voiture à ce moment là parce
qu'ils allaient les vendre à qui a
personnes réquisitionnées toutes ces
entreprises pour fabriquer des masques
et donc et tout ça ils n'ont pas fait ce
genre de choses et puis les décisions
administratives qui met dix ans on nous
parle de galère on aura plus de guerre
et il faut des semaines et des semaines
pour prendre une décision pour normes et
des dd mc alors qu'on nous parle d'une
situation d'urgence
le désamour mais il est évident vous
parlez de l'italie l'italie
sauf que l'italie à une situation très
particulière qui est favorable justement
aux populistes
parce que les populistes l'europe n'a
pas été présente comme il l'aurait fallu
être présent et il avait déjà connu avec
la crise des migrants
ça faisait des années qu'ils ont parlé
personne le rock n'a pas été à leur
secours
aujourd'hui il ya cette crise là la
manière dont elle est gérée ce sont les
russes et les chinois qui profitent de
cette situation et qui arrive qu'ils
nettoient les rues ce sont les
militaires les militaires russes qui
viennent nettoyer les rues en italie et
les chinois qui aide les italiens donc
est une mine d'or pour les populistes
dont ils s'appuient là-dessus et boris
johnson c'est pareil bon il en sort il
ay le début il a pris ça de manière très
désinvolte quand dj et puis il se dit
quand il a compris que c'était grave
il a quand même pris la décision de
confiner à leur manière mais il a quand
même réagi à ce moment là en plus
lui-même est tombé malade il donc
d'aller à quand même voilà une espèce de
zone à bâtir et à son voile a dit oui
mais c'est parce que nous avions d'abord
été long à venir ce qui me semble être
moi le péché originel de cette affaire
c'est l'organisation des élections
municipales
je pense que l'organisation des
élections municipales à thé profonde
erreur je pense qu'elle est extrêmement
partagées c'est bien là le problème
aujourd'hui n'est pas la faute des
heures parce que la responsabilité
suprême quand il ya maréchal foch à la
tête
n'est ce pas à décider et en fonction de
ces critères qu'ils apprécient lui-même
il est le chef
or emmanuel macron a décidé d'organiser
ces élections municipales semble-t-il
aujourd'hui à contrecoeur sous la
pression d'un certain nombre de leaders
de l'opposition
donc si vous voulez on a apprend une
politique en gros on nous a expliqué que
ces élections municipales avait été
organisée avec l'assentiment de
l'ensemble un de personnel politique de
gauche à droite et que ne pas les faire
aurait été une erreur majeure or les
avoir faits a été une erreur
fondamentale dans cette crise et afrique
la france et retrouvée dans les pays les
plus touchés par le
l'épidémie est cette pandémie est là il
va y avoir un problème de sortie de
crise car l'opposition ne pourra pas
dire c'est la france invité du pouvoir
puisque l'opposition a fait pression sur
le pouvoir légal lieux et donc avec
cette habitude française pas seulement
français fera que nous avons là des
faits de trouver tout le temps des
responsables il me falloir qu'on soit
ingénieux là qui va-t-on rendre le
responsable de cela ils ont été tous et
je pense qu'il y aura une défiance
générale qui existait déjà dans cette
crise mais à l'égard du monde politique
qui va te dire qu'il peut devenir assez
dangereuse car n'oubliez pas de
calendrier électoral ne s'est pas
arrêtée avec la pandémie dont va vers
des élections le président bridel
régionales
est ce que votre section est large en un
mot sur les sur le deuxième tour d'aidés
dès les élections municipales donc
probable qu individu au mois de juin
mais il ya didier deschamps avec le
président du conseil général tu es du
conseil départemental des yvelines qui
plein pour qu'elle ait lieu
laurent bazin rim penser qu'elle
pourrait avoir lu écouté sur les des
nominés éléments qui ont été envoyés
entre autres conseil d'état c'est pas la
date du mois de juin qui est retenue ce
sont des élections qui devaient avoir
lieu plus tôt à la rentrée
moi j'ai tendance à suivre un petit peu
ce qui est envoyé comme projet de loi
mme sont des ballons d'essai donc je ne
crois pas au mois de juin je crois plus
vraisemblablement la dernière semaine de
septembre est la première semaine
d'octobre où je partage tout ce qui
vient d'être dit il sans en dire plus
effectivement je peux confirmer pour
l'avoir vécu de près que le lançant des
parties sont impliquées dans cette
affaire puisqu'ils ont été nombreux à
mettre la pression effectivement pour
qu'elle ait lieu rapidement sachant que
la pub quand marche en réalité penchait
plutôt pour un décalage mais
effectivement les calculs électoraux des
uns des autres se disait que mieux
valait faire vite c'est évidemment un
avantage plutôt de c en place
d'éventuelles entrants donc
effectivement y compris y compris par
exemple allant du sénat je sais que
cette pression a été mise mais je me des
erreurs lourdes là dessus en ce qui
concerne l encours je peux donner cette
expérience à nous on avait décidé ce qui
a été fait
notre liste en tout cas de ne pas faire
de kantène hector et que leur ville est
arrivée nous avons arrêté tous les porte
à porte et toutes les opérations de
démarchage justement se disant qu'on
pouvait attraper mais surtout on pouvait
contaminer des gens simplement d'un an
portée politique
donc ça nous a semblé effectivement de
ne pas être une bonne chose ça nous a
promis d'aller en huile aux résultats
parce que les campagnes n'ont pas lieu
jusqu'au bout mais ça ne sent plus
confiant ce ne ne pas prendre le risque
de 2 puisse contaminer de il se
contaminer voilà donc il y aura des
suites
et pour répondre je ne pense pas au mois
de juin je pense plus plus
vraisemblablement à la dernière semaine
de septembre est la première semaine
d'août
donc après vous en dirons donc avec un
premier tour qui se jouera donc quand il
part au garros mais c'est moins grave
pour l'ordre sur les tissus de cette
crise alors peut-être jean-charles la
journée christian borie mais j'aimerais
juste qu'il y ait le vrai procès n'ont
pas de d'une personne mais de
l'administration
quand vous voyez les agences nationales
les agences nationales c'était là une
tête de turc de manuel valls il voulait
les supprimer ça coûte 50 milliards au
pays
50 milliards au pays l' agence nationale
de la santé l'agencé nationale de
l'observatoire de ce que voulait
l'agencé nationale du médicament lagence
on les entend oui mais c'est un c'est un
labyrinthe j'aimerais que à la sortie de
la crise
on est donc le procès de
l'administration qu'on revoie les
process à administrer et qu' on puisse
avoir quelque chose de clair de limpide
de rapides et qu'ils puissent se
mobiliser et non pas trace -
justificatifs d'un certain nombre de
statues de grades et de et de position
et j'espère qu'il va y avoir non pas
grenelle parce que c'est il sert c'est
reparti dès qu'on parle de grenelle on
découvre dans une usine à gaz mais
j'espère qu'il va y avoir des décisions
rapides qu'on va pouvoir tailler dans
l'est dans les organigrammes et avoir
des gens eux à la bonne place et qu'ils
soient eux mobilisables parce qu'il y
aura d'autres
l'autre événement comme celui que nous
traversons christos pensez vous que l'on
peut confier à des gens qui ont ce même
sortie de l'école nationale
d'administration
le fait
primé l'administration ou peut-être
vont-ils créé l'administration en charge
de supprimer l'administration d'arrivée
n'ont pas toutes les ligues du système
des élites aujourd'hui en france mais
mais il ya aussi un problème peut-être
de l'efficacité parce que si on a une
impression par exemple que le l'hôpital
que la santé publique était totalement
délaissées or on voit par exemple que
dépensent plus dans notre départ en
pourcentage de pib la france dépense
plus pour la santé que l'allemagne hors
salaires de mieux marché en est le
maître donc il ya peut-être aussi des
problèmes de fonctionnement dont 15 % de
la masse salariale des hôpitaux
c'est pour de l'initiation et pour
l'extraction stéphane dion se roulait
pas défendre pour l'administration obama
moi j'ai si vous voulez je je je je suis
fonctionnaire de l'état et j'en suis je
dors je tire une fierté nyon c'était une
situation que que que j'apprécie puisque
je vois là je vais me servir l'intérêt
général mais mon statut fait que je suis
totalement totalement dépendants et je
suis la plus en tant qu'observateur
qu'en tant qu'acteur si vous voulez mais
simplement ce discours sur les lourdeurs
administratives une efficacité
l'inadaptation des élites et on l'entend
depuis
alors tel qu'il est formulé aujourd'hui
depuis à peu près de 1946 et il n'y a
pas un législateur il voit une
législature au cours de laquelle on voit
un train de une dizaine de textes notes
relatif à la simplification de
l'administration la simplification du
droit
on parle depuis une trentaine d'années
de quatre formes ans de l'administration
donc tout cela c'est un discours qui a
tendance à tourner un peu en boucle et
qui éludent les vraies responsabilités
les vraies responsabilités elles ne sont
pas administrative de mon point de vue
est le futur l'administration c'est le
mot armée du politique et la
responsabilité du politique est les
ultimes mancelle du citoyen puis ce sera
encore une fois nous avons
les élus que nous voulons les élus
numérique tôt regardez la réaction du
corps électoral
lorsque un gouvernement où des candidats
aux élections législatives et
présidentielle propose par exemple la
réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
objectivement le nombre de
fonctionnaires se réduit depuis c'est
une tendance globale alors qu'il se
réduit pas de la même manière partout
mais les fonctionnaires de l'état en
tous cas elle en a de moins en moins
regardez la réaction du corps électoral
lorsqu'il s'agit de dégraisser le
mammouth de dégraisser la fonction
publique vous avez une partie des gens
qui sont jusqu'au boutiste et qu'il faut
plus de fonction publique et puis vous
en avez vous en avez d'autres qui disent
les services publics ils font les
protéger et c'est alors que tout cela
soit complexe
je l'entend bien mais la responsabilité
ultime
elle n'est pas administrative de mon
point de vue elle n'est pas non plus du
côté de l'école nationale
d'administration qui et quoi qu'on en
dise depuis 1946 une une qui produit en
tout cas depuis 46 et 50 8
avant c'était il ya une autre chose mais
qui produisent plutôt de bons
administrateurs gazier gens bien et pas
bien partout mais du côté des animateurs
qui sortent de l'ena
le niveau est encore extrêmement vont
voir souvent excellents au regard de ce
qu'on fait par exemple dans d'autres
systèmes juridiques donc la
responsabilité n'est pas à l'écouté de
l'administration elle est du côté du
pouvoir politique et ultime mandat peut
renaître à trop se mouiller pour réagir
oui parce que là je je je je bous mais
là franchement je suis outré par ce que
j'ai entendu parce que on ne peut pas
c'est qu'il s'agit pas de faire le
procès de des fonctionnaires dans leur
globalité
il s'agit pas le sujet l'a d'ailleurs
n'est même pas la question de la
suppression
moi je vais vous dire mon point de vue
moi je suis pour qu'ils aient plus de
fonctionnaires parce que là où on à
délester les légendes de de l'état se
soucie c'est souvent dans les quartiers
populaires ou dans les zones rurales où
là il ya un problème profond où les gens
demandent qui est plus d'état parce que
là où l'état est absent ce sont les
obscurantistes qui prolifèrent et on le
voit d'ailleurs on l'a vu c'est ces
dernières années avec tout ce qui s'est
passé avec les questions de terrorisme
de violence et tout ça bon donc
mais la vraie question moi je vais vous
dire les n'a produit des calculatrices
ce sont des gens qui n'ont qui ne
calculent ou à pau qu'est l'humain n'a
pas d'importance
ils ont des chiffres ils doivent pour
deux ce qui compte ce sont les chiffres
clés parce que la plupart des hauts
fonctionnaires
la plupart des hauts fonctionnaires
c'est ça et la question de
l'administration elle est fondamentale
je peux vous dire que pour avoir
rencontré beaucoup beaucoup de
fonctionnaires ou de hauts
fonctionnaires
je peux vous dire des fois qu'on vous
leur parlez de la réalité de la france
entre guillemets comme disait jadis
raffarin de la france d'en bas mais ils
vous disent mais non mais vous êtes dans
des fantasmes
alors que ce sont les réalités que nous
vivons que moi même je vive
je vis et que je vivais d'ailleurs
lorsque je parlais à ces gens là donc
et ils vous le 10 ans les politiques
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que moi je
pense que le politique devrait reprendre
même le pouvoir sur l'administratif
parce que les politiques idée vous
disent mais on y passe nous on est
toujours là donc c'est nous qui prenons
c'est nous qui décidons
voilà donc c'est comme ça que ça se
passe donc il faut il faut il faut
savoir le le le
je pense que ces gens d'ailleurs on
devrait dans leur cursus
il faudrait qu'ils aillent vivre en zone
rurale ou dans un quartier populaire
pendant au moins 6 mois 1 an on
comprendre la réalité de notre france on
pouvoir rendre des décisions
et puis la lourdeur administrative il
faut à change en pleine période de crise
m six mois ou deux mois ou trois mois
pour de bon une décision si on retourne
sur les normes d'un masque enfin c'est
ce qu'on aime
il ya il ya une leçon quand même
fondamental qu'on peut tirer de tout est
lié et qui va à contrario de tout ce qui
vient d'être dit aujourd'hui c'est
l'extraordinaire mobilisation du
personnel médical pendant cette crise
alors il des mois nous avons tous
que l'hôpital était en crise pour
beaucoup de raisons d'ailleurs donc on
peut parler là qui serait trop longue
mais on n'en font tout ça n'a plus
compté tous ces gens là se sont
mobilisés ont sauvé des vies ont
précédés je dirais les décisions
politiques
on a bien vu même que dans certaines
régions ils se sont mis en péril d'une
manière absolument incroyable et que au
fond ça nous laisse ça laisse cette
conversation sur une note d'espoir les
mozzarellas il y a des gens qui se
lèvent et qui sont là ça ça nous ramène
à la discussion sur les médecins les
preuves sur les profs qui voulaient pas
venir enseigner aujourd'hui pour vous
allez prendre des risques et sur la
saison là n'ont rien à regarder
esi sont allés ils ont sauvé des vies au
détriment de leur propre vie et j'en
parle alors moi je suis un peu short il
t'en parler mais bon je voulais dire en
effet à l'hôpital les médecins ont
repris le pouvoir pendant cette crise et
on met un lit à gauche rien s'il n'y
avait pas une réunion de commission pour
savoir s'ils n'ont pas les bêtes le lie
à gauche on mettait la gauche parce
qu'on était dans l'urgence donc 1 à vous
allez voir pardon donc bien qu'un espoir
voir le stade marche comme ça mais vous
allez voir que les cadres et autres qui
est et en télétravail ou qui étaient
chez eux et qu'ils n'étaient pas au
front vont revenir et sans doute là
cette espèce de pieuvre administrative
va reprendre le pouvoir sur l'hôpital et
on va retomber dans le bassin du relais
problème je suis pas sûr que les
français dans les français vous avez vu
les les études d'opinion qu'on a un sur
la perception de tout ces professionnels
aujourd'hui 28 des français au sahel
je pense que alors tous points de vue là
il y aura un avant et un après la crise
ces professions l'a1 ces gens là sont
sacralisés et pour un bon bout de temps
d'autant que je crois pas je crois pas
du tout nous savons tous en plus c'est
pour ce type d'épidémie
2pendant pandémie et de crise sanitaire
reviendra ça frère joris 20 21 22 23 24
on ne sait pas on voit bien que le
bouleversement de la nature les
problèmes environnementaux vont créer et
recréer halanzy ce type de crise
donc je pense que là on a une voix
un espoir de regarder les choses
autrement et de prendre les choses en
main autrement comme l'ont fait ces
professions de santé
je ne parle pas que des médecins
regardez les infirmières qui sans masque
aller au combat contre ce virus allait
sauver des gens beaucoup plus âgée que
pour la plupart je trouve que ça a été
un déploiement de d'humanité à et je
trouve que c'est 100 et émouvant
regardez les gens qui à 8h manifeste
pour ces gens là ça vaut tous les
sondages du monde et je crois vraiment
que quand on peut aussi aller vers ça
alors son roi la matiz est effectivement
le le l'énarchie moi je dirais plus que
l'ena qui ne paraît pas être un problème
non plus l'establishment on va dire qu'à
pas compte mais c'est pas un problème
c'est un problème de de l'administration
de bases c'est c'est le c'est le gars
qui ne signent pas là qui ne met pas le
temps de pont pour la certification
afnor sursis non mais c'est plus gras
que ça pardon c'est plus grave que ça
quand vous voyez la triste oui la
toiture de la droite face à la grogne
des infirmières on a des vraies raisons
de se poser des questions dans ce pays
core sur la capacité qu'ont certaines
corporations avec d'imposer leur loi
réservé aux moments là au moment
critique
justement alors le temps qui nous est
imparti malheureusement est gaulé comme
on dit mais je voudrais juste peut-être
d'une conclusion parce que si on vous
écoute et on écoute on voit au fond que
cette crise est là peut être agrandi de
fracture a grandi différences entre les
régions les différences entre les uns et
les autres et puis il y avait aussi
parfois un espoir d'union nationale elle
aime combret cette crise qu'est ce que
vous pensez bien justement tu y vas en
santé has come être plus unis ou plus
divisés qu'avant
en un mot parce que c'est vraiment une
conclusion qui nous faut une union
nationale dans la division ça va arriver
vite peut-être ça c'est christophe s'il
n'y a pas d'union nationale c'est que la
situation n'est pas grave on va voir une
france le coupé en deux une france qui
bosse
et puis une france qui se complaît dans
son droit de retrait
dans son inde dans son poujadisme donne
dans ce qu'il a de pire dans son côté
gilet jaune on dans les critiques contre
l'ena qui légende ena qui ne seraient
que des calculatrices enfin en yacht à
de la caricature et il va y avoir des
gens qui vont bosser il ya des gens qui
continuent à bosser
et puis des gens qui vont dire allons-y
embrassons nous folleville on est
tranquille l'argent tombe à la fin du
mois compte contentons nous de ce droit
de retrait bien sympathique
ne prenons aucun risque est d'augmenter
la terre opéra bientôt dix ans prost
peut-être moi moi j'aime bien je suis un
optimiste convaincu un utopiste
convaincu mais j'avoue que quand je vois
la réaction des gens quand j'ai vu la
réaction des gens avec les dénonciations
des voisins et tout ça est un titre oui
c'est bien d'applaudir à 20h les les
infirmières et tout ça mais quand est ce
que pour donner des coups quand elle
manifestait il n'était pas là et je suis
pas sûr que si après la crise allaient
manifester
la grande majorité de ces gens là serait
derrière je suis pas convaincu mais
j'aime beaucoup son optimisme quand même
il faut il faut qu'on ait de l'espoir
donc l onglet ce point normes et de riz
la france reste la france rappelez-vous
qu'en cas de crise lorsqu'on était en
pleine guerre au sein du conseil
national de la résistance on était loin
d'union nationale ça nous a pas empêchés
de gagner la guerre quand même c'est
notre particularisme
d'ailleurs notre émission en est le
témoin d'un débat on n'est pas tous
évidemment ça nice sa nuit et parfois
l'efficacité la france reste la france
sinon nationale bien c'est de débattre
en réalité la fin c'est terrible mais
juste moi moi je pense que l'union
nationale a souhaité en revanche si
souhaitable c'est que chacun puisse
parler et en même pas écouter l'autre en
effet quand je rejoins laurent la
démocratie c'est d'abord ça c'est le
libre dépendantes
patrice j'aime bien la formule
d'einstein pourrait rester de suis moi
je préfère être optimiste et avoir tort
que pessimistes et avoir raison c'est
vrai la nouvelle formule merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup elles sont servies sans
rost j'en ressors le joli et christophe
maury perd très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de pâques parce que voyez que les
débats il y en a besoin et ils sont
nombreux
merci à tous
[Musique]